Speaker 2: There's a very
Speaker 1: good article in the
Atlantic called Trump's next coup has already
begun and the article is by Barton Gellman. And
Barton's main argument is that
January 6th was essentially practice.
Speaker 2: It was a dry
Speaker 1: run of new techniques and tactics
to subvert an election. And Gellman says that
now Donald Trump's GOP, whether Trump himself
is part of it or not, and that's a really
important thing. Whether or not Trump is
part of Trump's GOP, they are now much better
Speaker 2: positioned to subvert the next
Speaker 1: election. And Gellman points out, among
a number of important things that the next coup is
likely to look a lot less like a coup and this
is what's so dangerous and pernicious about it.
Speaker 2: And it's
Speaker 1: really like if you if you
have one takeaway from this story, it's
Speaker 2: the coup is going to
Speaker 1: look a lot less like
a coup. If you can make the coup
Speaker 2: attempt not look like
Speaker 1: one, it is way more likely to
succeed and it's way more likely to raise eyebrows
and ruffle feathers. After the 2020 election.
And even in the lead up where Trump was already
talking about, I might not accept the results, et
cetera, Trump's actions looked like a
coup attempt. The Jan. six insurrection
Speaker 2: blatantly looked like a coup
Speaker 1: attempt. Trump trying to strong arm
Mike Pence obvious coup attempt. But the next
one might not so obviously look like a coup.
They tried it in 2020 in a pretty damn brazen way.
But after seeing what worked and what didn't work,
now they're in a position to be
able to set up the next attempt
Speaker 2: slightly more surreptitiously.
Speaker 1: They're setting up systems to
have Partizan control over which ballots are
counted and which ballots are thrown out.
Speaker 2: They're creating Partizan
Speaker 1: mechanisms to certify or
reject election results on the basis of party
lines. And as Gellman writes in The Atlantic and
read the article, we're linking to it, it's very
good. They are driving out or stripping power from
election officials who refuse to go along with the
coup attempt. From last November and December and
January, I mean, the attempt really lasted quite
a long time. And remember that even their legal
arguments failed in 2020. They had those dozens
of court challenges. They were all thrown out,
but they are fine, fine tuning or calibrating.
I guess we could say the legal aspects as well
to have a better shot if next time they
use slightly less crazy legal arguments
Speaker 2: and they have slightly
Speaker 1: more right leaning judges that get to
decide, maybe they actually get something done. So
that's the behind the scenes now. The plain view
Speaker 2: piece is an important part
Speaker 1: because it's not just what you
do behind the scenes, it's what's the public
Speaker 2: attitude to what you're doing.
Speaker 1: They are continuing to hammer publicly
Speaker 2: on people
Speaker 1: with the results. Can't be trusted.
Speaker 2: Anybody might have one. The results
Speaker 1: aren't secure. The claims of fraud are
generally true. The idea there is you fine tune
the mechanisms behind the scenes.
Speaker 2: You create
Speaker 1: a
Speaker 2: public that
Speaker 1: believes you can't
trust the results. You're much
more likely to set yourself up for some level of
Speaker 2: success, both by having the tactics
Speaker 1: in place and by having as much of
the population as possible in a state of mind
where they say, I don't really know who won,
Speaker 2: let them do it, let them do
Speaker 1: this because it's not even really
Speaker 2: clear who won, because there's so
Speaker 1: much fraud. You create a
public, more willing to accept a reversal.
On the basis of supposed fraud.
Speaker 2: And meanwhile, you work the
Speaker 1: systems that will actually allow you
to do it, hoping enough people look the other way,
and this is why I continue to insist
the 2020 Big Lie and the insurrection.
It's a horror not just for what it was
Speaker 2: on the
Speaker 1: merits, but it's a horror for
what it might open the door to in the future.
Speaker 2: Because I don't want to say it almost
Speaker 1: worked, but it came closer to having an
impact than we would like to see.
Speaker 2: And I hate to
Speaker 1: say this because it's
Speaker 2: really scary.
Speaker 1: I don't know that Joe Biden and
the current slate of Democrats are really
set up to fight it. I'm not saying they're
incapable, but they don't seem to either
be paying enough attention or be willing enough
to really do what it takes. There's not enough
public awareness here about the fact that this is
not. It's not like, Oh, we tried a coup in 2020.
Speaker 2: We didn't get it.
Speaker 1: That's it. Now we're going to try
to win on policy. Right? I mean, that's not what
they're doing. There are not enough safeguards
being put in place to counter what Republicans
have done in the last year. And quite frankly, I
mean, you could even go back and say what happened
in 2000 in Bush v. Gore? With the Supreme Court,
Katherine Harris, Florida, that should have been
maybe it was, I mean, it should have been a signal
Speaker 2: that
Speaker 1: they are going to do it again
and they're going to try harder and harder and
they are going to try to win, not by getting more
Speaker 2: votes, by earning
Speaker 1: votes. They're
going to try to do it with voter suppression,
gerrymandering. And now this new level, which is
just saying we won and trying to sue their way
into office, the left may partially be weaker,
but also the left is not even playing
the same game. The right have given
up on governance and policy completely. They've
given up on convincing voters what we offer is
better and we can prove it. They certainly will
say what we offer is better because they're
offering communism, which is a lie. But they are
about cultural issues. They're about owning the
Speaker 2: libs, they're about winning
Speaker 1: by gerrymandering and cheating.
Everything they do is done with the next election
in mind, how can we take the next election?
This applies to voters as well during
Bush and Obama. Republicans would say
using the military is good. You're alpha if you
want to send the military here and there. And
Bush was good because he did it. And Obama Obama's
bad because he's not doing it. Under Trump,
it then became, well, now war is bad war that
Hillary will get us into wars. Vote Trump because
Speaker 2: war is now bad under Biden,
Speaker 1: getting out of Afghanistan goes back
to being bad. Trump would have done it better. He
would have done it later or earlier or differently
better. This is the asymmetry problem that
I've pointed out that they are operating in
a completely different way and it's going
to be even more noticeable going forward.